foreign
new at six tonight as we track the
housing market here in the valley the
high cost of rent continues to impact
thousands of residents to make that
monthly payment now some are seeking
relief with short-term or even a weekly
rental but one resident tells us that
option there really isn't any any better
Christian gassadas has today's rent
crisis report
well Denise Ruby Taylor tells us those
weekly rentals are very attractive
because of the low cost of rent but at
least it was for her but she says now
things have changed her rent has gone up
and the quality of her unit is just flat
out embarrassing
I don't have safety there's always a
fear Ruby Taylor has been living at this
complex near Tropicana and Valley View
for over three years and she says her
living conditions are embarrassing it's
a big homeless population around here
the cars are getting broken too that's
what I'm hearing a lot of the units have
roaches that's what
goes on here you're battling with the
roaches in the inside why don't you move
somewhere else how can I the 60 year old
tells us the high cost of rent all
across the valley is keeping her from
moving her rent is 14.55 and without a
lease she says that would add an extra
200 bucks the rent is so high how can
you I make
at least you know I don't never know
what month I'm able to stay
organizations like help of Southern
Nevada is one of many resources in Las
Vegas they offer a variety of services
and programs to Residents in need Taylor
says any help is welcome as a cost for
everything keeps going up everything I
mean you go in the store where you used
to spend a hundred dollars and bring out
a few bags
you spend a hundred dollars today and
you might bring out one bag what can you
do
you know everything has gone up
well did we did reach out to the
apartment complex about this issue but
we have not heard back now as for Taylor
she tells us that during these tough
times she hopes to move in with her son
very soon because she says it's very
important for families to stick together
now if you at home if you're looking for
any type of assistance head over to our
website 8newsnow.com